falzon et bio ntech annoncé cette
semaine que leur vaccin expérimental
était efficace à plus de 90% selon des
résultats préliminaires
la nouvelle a fait le tour du monde il
faut dire que depuis le début de la
pandémie de kobe 19
les vaccins sont présentés comme la
solution pour mettre fin à la crise
sanitaire
reste maintenant à savoir quand et
comment y arriver
tant qu'il y aura pas de vaccin vaccin
sera vacciné les vaccins un vaccin
on compte sur lui pour nous sortir de ce
cauchemar collectif celui du confinement
des interdictions et de l'isolément
grâce à lui on pourra enfin laissé
tomber nos masques et tout ce qui vient
avec un vaccin pour nous ramener à notre
vie d'avant mais quand et comment
d'habitude il faut au moins dix ans pour
développer un vaccin des années de
recherches en laboratoire suivi de tests
sur les animaux sur les humains sans
compter l'homologation la production et
la distribution du produit
pour mettre fin à la crise sanitaire on
espère réduire ses délais de manière
spectaculaire
à quel point tour d'horizon avec trois
experts
[Musique]
il y à déjà près de 250 vaccin contre la
copie de 19 en développement dans le
monde
le principe est toujours le même le
produit simule la présence du virus sras
skov 2 pour apprendre notre système
immunitaire à le reconnaître
pour s'en protéger andré veillette
immunologie ce membre du groupe de
travail sur les vaccins contre la kobe
19 sur les conseils de ce groupe
d'experts
le canada a passé les accords avec
plusieurs entreprises pharmaceutiques
pour réserver des doses de vaccin en
développement des produits qui ont
montré des effets encourageants lors des
premières phases d'essais chez les
humains mais évidemment la bataille
n'est pas gagnée
alors il ya encore beaucoup de défis en
avant et puis bon va falloir s'assurer
que les vaccins qui se développe et qui
se développe très rapidement soit à la
fois efficace et secure sécuritaire pour
que la population puisse en bénéficier
au maximum les vaccins choisi utilise
des technologies variées qui ont toutes
leurs avantages et leurs inconvénients
certains emplois par exemple des
protéines semblables à celles qui se
trouve à la surface du virus pour
stimuler une réaction avantage c'est une
technologie éprouvée et efficace
c'est peut-être là proche la plus sécure
ok pour l'instant parce qu'elle est la
plus connue et elle est la plus lente
aussi parce qu'il faut produire les
protéines
autre technologie les virus vecteurs une
partie du matériel génétique du strass
cov 2 est insérée dans un autre virus
inoffensif pour qui la transporte jusque
dans nos cellules qui produiront elle
même des éléments du virus avantage la
production est plus rapide
inconvénient le virus vecteur est
souvent un adénovirus déjà connus de
notre système immunitaire
donc c'est fort possible qu'on ait déjà
des réponses immunitaires préexistantes
contre l'élément adénovirus du vecteur
qui fait que peut-être le vecteur doit
être les who les protéines codées par le
vecteur pointe rapidement éliminés et
puis repos une immunisation efficace il
y a aussi des vaccins à arn comme celui
de father et biotech
on injecte directement une partie du
matériel génétique du virus à combattre
avantage la rn et facile à produire en
laboratoire
inconvénient c'est nouveau il n'existe
encore aucun vaccin arn sur le marché
aussi la rnc très instable et puis donc
faut garder les arn de très basses
températures dans des congélateurs très
spéciaux sont à moins 80 degrés alors
c'est pas tout le monde
toutes les cliniques qui ont des
congélateurs à moins 80 degrés celsius
donc c'est une complexité additionnel de
cette approche là
[Musique]
une dizaine de ces divers types de
vaccins sont actuellement testés sur des
milliers de volontaires pour vérifier
s'ils sont sécuritaires et efficaces
pour prévenir l'infection
ce qu'on appelle la phase 3 des essais
[Musique]
ou vu des résultats annoncés cette
semaine il s'est écoulé moins d'un an
entre l'apparition de lakovic 19 et la
découverte d'un premier vaccin pour la
contrer
[Musique]
à mon âge je suis professeur de maladies
infectieuses à l'université de mcgill au
centre de recherche que vous voyez en
arrière et aussi je suis l'objet médical
pour medicago médicago est une
entreprise de québec qui se spécialise
dans la production de vaccins dans les
plantes elles espèrent entamer la
troisième phase des essais cliniques de
son candidat contre la copie de 19
d'ici quelques semaines la phase iii
c'est plus crucial parce que c'est le
moment de déterminer l'efficacité dans
l'histoire de développement des vaccins
il y à des vaccins qui ont eu des
résultats prometteurs mais qui ont qui
ont une échec pendant la phase iii parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas suffisamment
efficace alors c'est inutile d'utiliser
un vaccin avec aucune efficacité ou avec
une efficacité plus ah bon aucun vaccin
est efficace à 100%
en réalité la plupart des agences de
santé sont prêtes à se contenter d'un
vaccin anti coville 19 efficace à 50
pour ça imaginons conteste un vaccin sur
trente mille personnes la moitié reçoit
le vaccin l'autre un placebo
ensuite on attend que le virus façon en
oeuvre et on compte les cas plus le
virus circule plus la réponse arrivera
rapidement si on dénombre 100 cas dans
le groupe qui a reçu le placebo et aucun
dans le groupe vacciné on conclura que
le vaccin est efficace à 100%
cilly à 100 cas dans le groupe placebo
et 50 dans le groupe vaccin l'efficacité
est de 50% plus les cas s'accumulent
plus on a de certitudes que le résultat
est juste
même en cinq ans pour cent l'impact chez
les gens âgés chez les gens avec les
comorbidités peuvent être extraordinaire
[Musique]
bien sûr les essais sur de grandes
populations sont aussi essentiels pour
surveiller l'apparition d'effets
indésirables en matière de vaccins la
sécurité est primordiale
même si le vaccin est efficace des
complications qui vont peut-être la
rendre la vie misérable a déjà six et un
sur dix mille puis on donne le vaccin
est à 10 millions de personnes
alors ça fait pas mal de jeunes qui vont
avoir eu cette complication là alors si
on peut s'en passer il faut savoir c'est
sûr que même un sur 30000 même son test
30000 c'est encore possible qu'il va y
avoir des complications qu'on pourra pas
détecté mais bon un moment donné il faut
faire le poids des choses et aller de
l'avant
une fois les résultats compilés santé
canada évaluera ses données sur la
sécurité l'efficacité et la qualité des
vaccins produits
ce processus a été accéléré mais il
faudra quand même plusieurs mois avant
qu'un vaccin soit autorisé la
disponibilité de ces produits est aussi
un enjeu la production industrielle de
vaccins est un processus étroitement
contrôlée qui prend du temps pour
réduire les délais des installations ont
été construites pour fabriquer à grande
échelle des vaccins dont on ne sait même
pas encore s'ils répondront aux attentes
mais le principe a des limites
même les géants quand tu fais comme à
djendjen il parle d'une capacité de 1
milliard vaccin doses de vaccin en 2 12
mois
et si on a besoin de deux dos pour
chaque personne même les géants peuvent
protéger seulement un demi milliard
jackson a par année pour protéger 7.8
milliards personnes du monde
ça prendra un douzaine de ces vaccins on
pourrait donc commencer à vacciner les
personnes les plus à risque fin 2020
au début 2021 la population générale
elle risque de devoir attendre la
deuxième moitié d'année prochaine
comment optimiser ensuite
l'administration de ces vaccins à la
population je suis professeur à l'école
de santé publique de nos merci je suis
chef de l'unité de recherche clinique
appliquée ici au centre de recherche du
chu sainte justine
[Musique]
avec ses collègues
l'épidémiologiste et biostatisticien
développe un modèle pour maximiser
l'impact des futures campagnes
d'immunisation et là on se place dans la
situation savoir un bon avec peut-être
un certain nombre de doses disponibles
des priorités de vaccination des
caractéristiques du vaccin aussi son
efficacité
comment on pourrait introduire une
campagne de vaccination et surtout lever
les mesures préventives
les vaccins seront inefficaces à 50 75
90 % comme vient de l'annoncer father
seront celles sécuritaire et efficace
surtout chez les plus jeunes aussi chez
les personnes âgées chez les enfants
combien de temps durera l'immunité
provoquer
autant d'inconnus qui pourront faire
varier les faits de la vaccination sur
la courbe de l'épidémie
son néon être une campagne de
vaccination qui commence par exemple mai
2021 est-ce que c'est raisonnable de
penser qu'on peut lever une mesure
préventive par exemple permettent
l'école en présentiel au cégep à
l'université en septembre
alors on modélise point c'est de voir
quelles caractéristiques on aurait
besoin de vaccin quel type de campagne
de vexer la vaccination dont on a besoin
pour permettre ce genre de déconfinement
la levée des mesures sanitaires sera
donc un processus graduel
reste à savoir à quel point c'est très
difficile de dire si ça va prendre
seulement quelques mois ou plusieurs
années mais c'est certain que ça sera
pas instantanée peut-être à la fin 2021
on aura vacciner suffisamment déjà pour
que l'on puisse commencer à voir les
effets bénéfiques pour dans un an
soit je pense que c'est le bon scénario
[Musique]
en attendant ce qui inquiète les
chercheurs c'est que la découverte d'un
vaccin ne sonne un peu trop vite le
début de la récréation dans l'esprit de
certains le prochain défi qu'on va avoir
c'est lorsqu'on débute les campagnes de
vaccination à séduire la population
on achète on voit la lumière au bout du
tunnel mais soyez patients il faut
maintenir certaines mesures encore un
but on a tous hâte de ranger nos masques
et de faire la fête
malheureusement ça ne se fera pas en
criant vaccin
[Musique]